Europe's moment that's what the 825
billion dollar proposed rescue deal put
forward by the EU executive Commission
is being called dear Union Dean yelling
to those who look at the bold investment
today I say that tomorrow the cost of
inaction in this crisis will be much
more expensive this is about laying the
foundations of our future together and
at the same time to react appropriately
to a clearly defined extraordinary
crisis situation through no fault of our
own this new proposal will be in
addition to an earlier 592 billion
dollar package bringing the entire
effort to an estimated two trillion
dollars it's a financial stimulus that
is hoped will kick-start economies the
proposal still needs to be agreed by all
the 27 member states but big players
Germany and France have already backed
the plans economies have suffered under
lock downs but it's a human cost that
Spain mourn today politicians and
members of the royal family observed a
milot silence for the 27,000 who have
lost their lives during this pandemic
but as Europe begins to slowly move on
from the crisis and look to solutions
the UK Prime Minister is still under
fire over his special advisers alleged
contravention of lockdown rules
it's obviously extremely concerned
grilled by members of parliament Boris
Johnson was in no mood to answer
questions over the controversy that has
dogged him for five days you have a
choice between protecting Dominic
Cummings and putting the national
interest first but I think my choices
are the choice of the British people I
would want us all to make a bet and that
is as far as we possibly can to lay
aside a party political point-scoring
and put the national interest first
other parts of Europe are opened up
slowly
Croesus dobrik camping facility is one
of the first to reopen but it had just
four guests we came through the border
without problems we booked the camping
lot and we had to pay in advance
generally we traveled well and we liked
it it's somewhat empty there could be a
few more people the site has a capacity
over a thousand Croatia's economy like
many others are heavily dependent on
tourism but there's still a long way to
go before Europe recovers from this
pandemic Assad beg al-jazeera London